hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield finale video hold
a whole bunch of stuff we need to talk
about we know a little bit about what's
going on in season 3 especially with
some of the big WTS from the episode in
case you guys didn't hear about it too I
mean obviously agents of shield is
coming back for season 3 but agent
Carter was also renewed for season 2 so
I'll be doing videos for that when it
comes back in January so I'm just gonna
start with a really big stuff first
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode let's talk about fish oil as
silly as this plot point is this was
kind of like the workaround to the
Terrigen bomb so think of it as the TV
version of the Terrigen bomb in the
comics during Marvel's infinity event a
couple years ago blackbolt released a
terrigen bomb transforming all kinds of
people all over the earth into Inhumans
they said they did it the fishway to get
around the metal bits part doing an
actual terrigen bomb would have made
inhuman transformations much more
obvious they wanted it to be a little
more subtle they want to be a little
more selective about who becomes
Inhumans bombs tend to be a little more
indiscriminate and raise a lot more
questions because then you have to
address you know why isn't the news
talking about a giant bomb that went off
so you can see as integrated as the TV
shows are with the movies there's just
some things they're not quite ready to
roll that hard on yet so lots more
Inhumans coming next season project
caterpillar that special folder that
Coulson gave to Skye that's gonna be
like the secret warriors team that they
put together next season if you haven't
read the secret warriors storyline you
know it's a big Daisy Johnson storyline
which is the character that Skye is her
code name is quake that rose out of
Secret Invasion so that's actually a
pretty old storyline but it's a lot of
fun and they're taking a lot of
inspiration from it they're repurposing
a lot of elements so it's not gonna be a
carbon copy of secret warriors but
that's what secret caterpillar project
is all about caterpillars turn into
butterflies you get the metaphor they'll
find Inhumans that will blossom into
fully functioning members of shield
you know well-adjusted members of shield
on the other side of that coin you have
Ward who's putting together his evil
team he's not a new head of Hydra that's
not what he's doing he's just picking
the best bits of Hydra that are still
left around to put together a team think
of his team is more like an evil version
of Howling Commandos i know they said
that all the heads of Hydra are gone you
know Baron von Strucker died in Avengers
age of Ultron all the other ones are
either missing or dead
this is where Baron Zemo rises from he's
rumored to be one of the big villains of
Captain America Civil War so we're not
gonna hear about him til next year
they just included all that war dialogue
to let you know that they're not gonna
keep going back to Hydra as a source for
storyline that's one of the things I
feel like agents of shield has done
really well you know build itself its
own universe so that it doesn't have to
keep borrowing from the Avengers the
executive producer said that they're
trying to raise you know try to create
their own superheroes Daisy Johnson
obviously is someone from the comics
they will always continue to be people
from the comics that they do on the TV
show but they're not gonna be as
dependent as they have been in the past
like last season they made a big deal
about really depending on that samuel
l.jackson cameo at the end what about
the special blueprints that Fitz is
working on for Coulson those are like
the new quinjets it's kind of hard to
tell but when you look at the Quinn jet
from age of Ultron it's also an updated
design so you know they're just getting
like slightly better tech each year
speaking of resources obviously
Coulson's secret project last year was
all about making that new Helicarrier
this year they had the whole real shield
versus shield stuff going on now it's
just one shield Coulson is back at the
top I was a huge fan of Edward James
Olmos I thought he worked great on the
show for the storyline that he was a
part of but I don't feel like he fits
really well into that world so it makes
sense that they kill him off one of the
big things I'm looking forward to in
season 3 that I think is going to
course-correct shield a little bit as a
show is the inclusion of all these extra
super-powered people it's just a really
easy direction to go for more action
more comedy based on awkwardness with
powers and when you watch a superhero
show you expect to see spectacle along
with human drama shield does human drama
great like all the bits like the
Fitzsimmons stuff those moments are the
best I feel like it does that better
than any of the other comic book shows
but you look at a show like the flash it
just a spectacle way better than agents
of shield I'm talking like acid trip
mind-blowing special effects not like
the crazy CG porn that you see in age of
Ultron not like that level but you know
you get the idea you watch a superhero
show you expect to see superpowers along
those lines what about the obelisk it
totally ate Simmons at the end from the
interview that I read with the actress
she is not dead she thinks I mean the
actors thinks that it transported her
somewhere but the
producers haven't told her anything so
don't assume that Simmons is dead she's
either like in there somewhere or it
just transported her somewhere else just
like you'd expect that was my biggest
WTF from the episode along with Coulson
getting his arm chopped off it's just
like the whip pan from last season where
Coulson's splattered Garrett what'll
probably happen is is that in Episode
one they'll dress Simmons and Ian will
find out whether or not the actress is
still on the show like though they'll
probably tease that out they did that
this season - you know Simmons was away
we didn't know where she was and it
turned out they planted her in Hydra and
they just they didn't tell Fitz about it
so what about the rest of shield bobbi
and Hunter I know it sounded like
they're leaving shield like they were
gonna do a spin-off series that was what
that moment was shot for where she's
like I can't do this anymore that was
kind of intended to set up the spin-off
which they decided not to pick up
supposedly there's still a chance that
it might happen but I'm not I'm not
planning on it so there will be more
bobbi and Hunter next year and probably
more me not even though it seemed like
agent May left - in the context of the
story she just went on a long vacation
she's always been so uptight so like
that's why she was smiling so much at
the end of the episode she's just like
having the big job she's probably go
smoke a lot of pot we have to talk about
Skye's dad - he was absolutely
ridiculous in this episode you know it
in a good and bad way he is playing a
comic book character his character in
the comics is called mr. Hyde he's like
he turns into a big mr. high person the
formula also right out of the comics
it's like the poor man's version of a
Super Soldier Serum Kyle MacLachlan
though just feels like he doesn't fit in
this comic book universe like he was way
too over-the-top maybe some of you liked
how silly he got but it just felt a
little weird to me Kyle MacLachlan works
better in like the Twin Peaks universe
where he is the agent coulson person
that's kind of who his character is in
the Twin Peaks universe he is like the
Phil Coulson of Twin Peaks one of the
other things that really surprised me
was the left-turn blood Skye's mom
Deacon Lachman was also on the hundred
she kind of played a similar type
character so I'm surprised I didn't see
that coming
it's kind of sad that they had to
sacrifice Raina for this storyline but I
think that they just didn't want to give
Skye an asset that would give her too
much power seeing the future is a huge
advantage so I think you know they just
want to keep the characters from getting
overpowered they like the idea of these
protagonists not knowing what's coming
next and when you have a character they
can tell you what's coming next it takes
away a lot of the suspense
you guys watch The Walking Dead adult
that's actually kind of how the writers
think on that series you know when
someone gets a little too overpowered
you know becomes too much of a safety
net for the other characters they
usually try to take that away so the
minute someone on agents of shield feels
like they get to invincible they're
probably gonna be the one to die that
season
Coulson very clearly not invincible what
is he gonna replace his hand with though
how about a vibranium Klaw if we're
gonna get black panther and Wakanda is
gonna integrate with the rest of the
Marvel Universe in civil war chances are
we'll get our hands on a lot more
vibranium seriously though he's probably
gonna get a stark tech hand and they'll
just make it look like a normal hand
like life model decoy hand just looking
at it from a practical standpoint the TV
show isn't gonna do anything that's
gonna require Coulson to put like
extensive makeup on every single week
it'll be some funny Patton Oswalt type
explanation so he'll still look like
Coulson but underneath he'll be part
robot here's my big question for you
guys what was your favorite moment from
the finale and what are you most looking
forward to in season 3 you know what
fish oil in humans are you looking
forward to seriously everybody be sure
to go out and start buying Marvel brand
fish oil pills what's probably gonna
happen is because there's like a lot of
brand-new TV shows that are releasing
material this week so I want to do all
those videos so I'm probably an Adu
shield Season 3 next week just looking
at the roster here's what we have in
terms of Marvel TV that's coming up
Jessica Jones
that's probably coming up later this
year they haven't announced an official
premiere date yet there's agents of
shield season 3 agent Carter season 2
daredevil season 2 that's gonna be next
year right around the time Captain
America premieres and then sometime
after that that same year probably Luke
Cage they've already cast Luke Cage but
most of the production right now that's
been going on has been Jessica Jones he
will be in the Jessica Jones series
though Luke Cage will be in Jessica
Jones be sure to subscribe to get all
that stuff if there's anything you guys
want me to do first
in terms of bonus videos besides agents
of shield season 3 just let me know in
the comments other big things happening
this week so they just made some big
announcements about Supergirl on CBS
arrow has its finale tonight so I'll be
doing a video for that just like normal
the flash finale is next week and the CW
up fronts are going to be on Thursday
this Thursday they'll be making a bunch
of announcements about the legends of
tomorrow spinoff series like the Justice
League team-up show there
whatever they end up announcing I'll do
bonus videos for it so don't worry I
will have some more Ant Man and Captain
America videos coming up you can
actually click here to learn about
what's going on with Captain America's
Civil War and you can click here to
catch up on last night's episode of the
flash if you haven't seen that yet thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you